welcome back to las vegas now the stress
and anxiety of the times whether it's
covet related homeschooling related
elections related it can all take away
from our much needed
self-care routine so i spoke with the
travel and lifestyle expert davey sutton
about her top three tips
for taking better care of yourself davey
welcome back
hi thanks for having me so good to see
you girl now i know you live in atlanta
but you made your escape much needed
escape where are you now
so i got myself a place from verbo
in the outer banks rocky i got remote
i got to a beach and i've been having
the best time and
this is actually my first tip is know
when
to take a break and we're actually
seeing this people especially for that
work from home crowd
people are packing their laptops and
going to more favorable places so verbo
is a company that's been around for a
long time so
they have entire homes which is one
kind of key element that works uh well
right now and also a huge inventory in
remote places like beaches and mountain
tops so
that combination makes it perfect for
the time that we are in right now
i would say nature is one of the the
best places you can go right now during
this time
so healing rocky slow healing the second
one is
keep self-care routines i have to admit
i have been so busy self-care just
on the back burner for me i've been kind
of focusing on my beauty routine and
and it's not to sound vain or anything
like that but just like slowing it down
looking in the mirror saying some
affirmations and it doesn't have to be
a big investment to get some good
quality
skin care products so one of the
products i want to tell you about is
olay regenerist micro sculpting cream
and i have to tell you rocky
it's been one of my go-to for ages
because
you know it just works it's instantly
moisturizing you can get it anywhere at
the drugstore at the big box stores for
under 30 bucks find a new me time hobby
is the third one
i that is so important we've seen people
kind of bake the breads during the
pandemic or build out a garden but
even more so i want you it can be
frivolous it doesn't even have to have a
purpose and what we've been seeing
is like adult coloring so you know not
just for kids
grabbing those coloring books and it has
proven
mental benefits as well it helps you
de-stress for me i like to
grab a coloring book at the end of the
day in my bed instead of just scrolling
on my phone grab my coloring book
my coloring pencils and just doze off to
sleep and
really fun i've come up with a series of
free traveling uh travel inspired
coloring books during the pandemic for
that reason
adult coloring books i say it's great
for ages four to one hundred and four
wonders of the world maps of the world
and
beauties of the world and i'm sending
you one rocky
but listen i will show you the pages
because i will start immediately
exactly so this is an example of how you
can kind of
de-stress and do some self-care during
the pandemic
and you can get them on amazon or any of
any book retailer and on my website
travel with davey
well those are going to be my new
obsession so thank you